قد يكون تهديد التغير المناخي للبشر هو
العنوان الابرز لتداعيه الحاليه
والمستقبليه لكنه لا يقل اهميه عن الخسائر
التي يتسبب فيها هذا تغير المناخي فتغير
المناخي مشاهدينا يكلف مختلف اقتصادات
العالم ثمنا باهظا فعل مد العقد الماضي
عده الكوارث المتعلقه بالطقس والمنى
والمياه الى تكبد العالم خسائر تتجاوز 200
مليون دولار في اليوم خلال ال50 عاما
الماضيه وفقا لارقامي مع هذه شركه التامين
سويس ار 8 نفس المؤسسه قالت ان الكوارث
الطبيعيه الناجمه بالدرجه الاولى عن
التغير المناخي تتسبب في خسائر بنحو فصل
3% من الناتج المحليه العالمي سنويه كما
ان الكلفه مرشحه للارتفاع في السنوات
المقبله وفقا لمؤسست دولهتها التي توقعت
ان يتكمل الاقتصاد العالمي خسائر تصل الى
مئه وثمانيه مليون دولار عند حلول لسنه
270 في حال وصلت درجات الحراره ارتفاع